the biggest and best trailers revealed
at comic-con plus et's craziest moments
at the convention
hiyee we are breaking new ground on the
daily denny today I'm wearing a hat I'm
Dani director in my best Jason mask
cosplay cuz we just got back from
comic-con and I didn't want to do my
hair I just couldn't sorry guys
but what a fantastic weekend it was in
San Diego a lot of great moments came
out of the con so many Studios offered
up fans a long awaited a glimpse at the
blockbuster films hitting the big screen
among the buzziest trailers was Aquaman
Jason Momoa is back as the king of
Atlantis in this action-packed trailer
that made a huge splash at Comic Con I
don't want to strap in
my brother has come from the service
challenge me for the throw my god an
ass-whooping
in case you couldn't tell from that
trailer Jason Momoa is a beast in person
I saw him walking right outside the et
interview suite and I was just like and
this trailer has me hyped for this movie
it's also the first time we're
introduced to his mother Queen atlanna
played by Nicole Kidman and he teased
Kevin Frazier chatted with her at her
very first comic-con about how she
joined the Aquaman family is it true
that the Atlanta um the art for it they
use your face originally because they
wanted you before you had even signed
yeah it's so funny because um James said
to me I still want you to do this and he
said and I'll prove to you that I've
always wanted you to do this you know my
renderings I drew you so what are you
gonna say are you gonna say well the DC
flick surfs into theaters December 21st
now sticking with the DC world it looks
like they might be moving away from
their motto of the grittier the better
with its upcoming superhero adventure
Shazam
exactly Levi plays a kid in foster care
turned powerful adult superhero
you have full immunity you're dead your
window welcome for not getting robbed oh
hey stop I'm a superhero tell me
Zach Levi is not perfect for this part
he's like Superman meets Tom Hanks and
big and I'm totally here for it
Shazam flies into theaters April 5th
next year now and the meantime will have
the fantastic be sequel the crimes of
Grindelwald November 16 and Eddie
redmayne's Newt Scamander is tasked with
bringing down villainous wizard Gellert
Grindelwald aka Johnny Depp you
underestimate your talents misters come
on
their arrogance is a key to our victory
muggles are not lesser
not disposable
your two could mute you never met a
monster you couldn't love you know
Johnny himself surprised the crowd at
the fantastic beasts to panel in
character for a brief two minute
monologue and Kevin Frazier talked to
the cast about that appearance he teased
comic-con Smith who the Johnny Depp was
humming did anybody know the weird one
was that we didn't know he was in the
first movie at all hmm I mean we should
all games without him and then they put
him in with just a few people so I
didn't even know he is looking at his
face I was like Johnny I was like who
you didn't have that on your head when
you man enough no of course okay have
what on my head but I heard the crowd
were crazy and that it really helped it
just made for a magical moment at the
panel it's their lives they live their
lives and then when he started speaking
it went silent you couldn't hear you
could hear a pin drop it was amazing
yeah
but that makes for the great moment
right yeah a really fun moment yeah
now Johnny wasn't the only one to do a
little cosplay at comic-con pieces
behind me bumblebee star John Cena hit
up our interview with him as our
favorite transformer and John felt right
at home at Comic Con because as our very
own Ashley Crossan found out he knows a
thing or two about being a legit fanboy
we are really big fans at our office how
you are a fan of BTS how do we get you
guys together how do we get guys to meet
so I'm petitioning to kind of be there
their secret bodyguard I'm currently
doing some business in China and China
is really close to Korea so you never
know what can happen I get closer to
them I think that's are you here in the
States though so we may be passing each
other yeah it's truly truly poor I'm I'm
a fan of fandom that's why I love places
like comic-con that's why I love WWE
because people show their passion
and when I became aware of the BTS
phenomenon it hit me by storm I listened
to their music I enjoy their music
j-hope is my favorite just because he's
got a little bit of street cred like
myself but I'm I really enjoy the
following and the passion they create I
think that that's something special and
especially for them to be the first to
take kpop and I think that's that truly
is a testament to how well they do their
job so I'm just a fan of what they do
and the passion of the Invo people you
gotta love how much John Cena stands for
BTS because so do I all right guys we
Came we saw we comic conquered there
were so many memorable moments this year
and et got plenty more scoop on the
blockbuster films and hit TV shows
coming to the big and small screens so
keep it locked with et online.com and
our official comic-con 2018 playlist on
e t--'s youtube channel go enjoy that
and I'ma take a nap bye
you
[Music]